president trump is beating joe biden for
the first time in a
major poll that's coming out from
rasmussen
rasmussen does weekly surveys found out
that president trump
is now getting 47 of the respondents
support
compared to joe biden at just 46 percent
and president trump's approval rating
among respondents
has surged to the highest level uh this
year
additionally on top of that according to
the washington examiner
that approval rating is at 52 percent
why is it because you can only ignore
the president's competence for so long
you can only ignore the democrats
incompetence for so long
this is making headway not just among
more voters than biden's voters not just
among
a slim majority of americans this is
making inroads most notably
among groups that the democrats have
taken for granted
i'm michael knowles the michael knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from
frosted ice pharaoh it says yesterday
trump was questioned about
not being presidential if he was
presidential he would not be making
middle east peace deals
that's true if you really want to be
presidential then you've got to just
start a whole bunch of wars in the
middle east
why i don't know we can probably tell
you why but this is a big divide and
actually it's on this issue of middle
east peace
that the competence of trump and the
incompetence
of the democrats is really clear because
there have been a lot of promises made
by
top democratic establishment politicians
and trump
just proved them all wrong we'll get to
that in one second first got to thank
our friends
over at ring speaking of security
speaking of how to stay
safe i love ring especially when i'm
traveling all around because
it gives me peace of mind it makes me
one feel like i'm living in the future
because i can check in on my home
anywhere whether i'm in the office
whether i'm on a beach somewhere whether
i'm on an airplane you can check in on
your home
it makes you feel safe makes you feel
secure in your home
and most importantly when i give this
out as a housewarming gift to friends
it's inexpensive so i seem like i'm
giving a very expensive gift even though
you don't have to shell out a ton of
money
you can do it all with this one simple
app with ring you can keep an eye on
your home
no matter where you are you can get a
special offer
on the ring welcome kit right now at
ring.com
knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s go do it in the
old end times
there used to be neighborhood watch
there used to be these super duper
expensive intricate uh security systems
now we have ring this is wonderful
sometimes technology really works for us
it comes with rings video doorbell 3 and
chime pro the perfect way to start your
ring experience plus you get two day
free shipping
go to com slash knowles w l e s do it
right now
feel safe and secure ring.com
knowles can wles not just that president
trump is making inroads you know among
the small
majority of the electorate or you know
more voters than biden
he's doing well with groups that the
democrats have typically relied on
groups identity groups that democrats
usually take for granted
most notably in recent days among gay
guys
yes that's right the homosexual
population
of the of the electorate tends to be
taken for granted by the democrats and
yet according to polling
from a queer dating app right now it
looks as though
45 of queer american men
now don't cancel me for saying that
that's their word
i don't know what word i'm supposed to
use they change the words every day but
45
of queer american men are backing
president donald trump and this is
considered a very queer fact
because democrats always believe that
they're supposed to get
a hundred percent of the gay guys the
app is called hornet
and uh uh 45 of them are going to vote
this is a
1200 queer american male respondents say
they're going to vote
for trump uh how did they get to this 10
000 men were surveyed by the app 12
identified as u.s citizens
51 said they'd be vote of those men said
they'd be voting for biden
and 45 for trump so it's very very close
even among
gay men and by the way these are just
the gay men who are on these apps
presumably the more bourgeois stayed you
know
calm gay men who are not on these apps
presumably they're even
more conservative than all that so why
why is it
why is president trump gaining momentum
he's gaining momentum
because joe biden is wrong about
everything and his views are unpopular
simple as that right because he's gotten
things wrong
with one or two exceptions for 50 years
a huge political career and his views
that even if they were at one time
popular are no longer popular
one example of this just one simple
example but it's a central one right now
is china china has not only destroyed
the global economy because of the
pandemic that they lied about
but china also has helped to destroy the
american economy
by stealing our jobs and they did they
you can't even say that they stole the
jobs
because a lot of american politicians in
both parties decided to outsource them
this was considered to be a wonderful
thing because gdp might tick up a little
bit
and who cares if whole towns of people
are going to die of opioid overdoses
and suicides that's not a big deal
because at least we can get slightly
cheaper consumer goods
the view that was held by the democratic
party and by i guess what you would call
establishment republicans
the total unfettered free trader
republicans was this is a good
thing a rising china is good for
everybody
yeah they might poison the whole world
with a plague and shut down the entire
economy but
you know generally speaking it's a good
thing and this was the view
explicitly held by joe biden there's a
debate here in the united states and
quite frankly throughout most of the
west is whether
a rising china was in the interest of
the united states and the wider world
as a young member of the foreign
relations committee i wrote and i said
and i believe
then what i believe now that a rising
china
is a positive positive development
not only for china but for america and
the world writ large
unambiguous i know that clip wasn't so
long ago but i know it's a little
jarring to hear joe biden speak
clearly so odd how his childhood stutter
that we've heard so much about in this
election campaign obviously wasn't there
in the clip because
even just a few years ago joe biden was
much more with it than he is today
he was with it he was just wrong about
everything notably about
china but we can clearly see what his
views were he's
wrong about other very popular issues
charter schools charter schools
school choice give students particularly
underprivileged students
particularly racial minority students
particularly students in the inner
cities
basically charter schools give them
their only chance
to get a better life to break out of
cycles of
poverty and misfortune and joe biden and
the democratic establishment opposes it
why does joe biden oppose school choice
i sat down yesterday with
education secretary betsy devos and
senator cruz for our show verdict
we talked a lot about this issue that
will be coming out very soon
but the long and long and short of it is
democrats oppose school choice
because they're bought off by the
teachers unions and the teachers unions
don't want that because it threatens
their
job even if they're very poor teachers
even if those students are failing
even if the schools are completely
underperforming
the teachers unions still want to get
theirs so they've made this unholy
alliance with the democratic party
joe biden puts it in no uncertain terms
he does not want
poor kids he does not want kids in bad
school districts to be able to get a
good education
i will not there will not be no federal
dollars
i'm not betsy devos nor will my uh my
secretary of education meaning like her
in terms of her attitudes about
public schools no
privately funded charter school
would receive or private charts will
receive a penny of federal money
none and any charter school that in fact
is worthy of being able to
be in education would have to be
accountable to the same exact school
boards
the same exact mechanisms that the
public school
is accountable to across the board there
has to be transparency
a lot of these charter schools are
significantly underperforming
significantly i can see where you can
have a school for example
a specialty school on the on the arts or
or
for music or but if you're going to have
a chart of school
it can't not come at the expense of the
public school
so everything he's saying is just
complete nonsense it doesn't make
it doesn't mean anything he's saying
that the charter schools are
underperforming
that's simply not true just just the
example of last year
new york city which is a very important
place for charter schools the
students in public schools
underperformed
the students in the charter schools and
and pretty significantly and we're
talking about public dollars and private
dollars a lot of these schools
were started with private dollars and
then you've got
programs that can transfer some public
money they're going to the failing
schools
and get those students to go to the
decent schools in new york you've got
tens of thousands of students on that
wait list
for charter schools why because of
course everyone wants to get into the
good schools
and what's the rub here public schools
could lose a billion dollars if those
students
transferred so a lot of money on the
line joe biden took that side
but across the aisle including groups
that democrats take for
for granted uh charter school is very
popular
it's even beyond biden don't forget
biden is nobody biden is an
empty suit he blows around in the wind
now he probably doesn't even know which
way the wind is blowing
he is a symbol of the democratic
establishment yesterday he forgot who
was at the top of the ticket he referred
to the harris biden ticket as though
kamala harris were
going to be the president joe biden's
going to be the vice president he's just
a
vessel for for democratic policies how
those policies play out
very poorly we saw two days ago an
historic peace deal in dc
i was sitting directly across the street
from the white house when that was
signed i was in the hotel with the
israeli and the bahraini delegation it
was pretty weird man
we've been told that middle east peace
is a pipe dream
now we're looking at peace deals not
just with israel and bahrain and the
united arab emirates but it could
include as many as nine additional
nations
including saudi arabia who's the big dog
in the region
and why did this happen because donald
trump bucked
the establishment foreign policy trend
specifically
the democratic foreign policy
establishment trend even though
the last democratic secretary of state
john kerry
told us that kind of a peace deal a
peace deal that dealt with the arab
nations
before dealing with the so-called
palestinian
state it's not a state but the
palestinian issue in israel
john kerry said that would be absolutely
impossible
until it was possible there will be no
separate peace
between israel and the arab world i want
to make that very clear to all of you
i've heard several prominent politicians
in israel sometimes
saying well the arab world is in a
different place now we just have to
reach out to them and
we can work some things with the arab
world and we'll deal with the
palestinians no
no no and no
i can tell you that reaffirmed even in
the last week as i have talked to
leaders of the arab community there will
be no advance
and separate peace with the arab world
without
the palestinian process and palestinian
peace
everybody needs to understand that that
is a
hard reality i love how these democratic
politicians who are
100 wrong on these issues joe biden on
china and john kerry on the middle east
make themselves so clear so that we can
just go back and see how wrong they were
in
john kerry's best thirst in hell with a
third voice it's because he goes
let me tell you something teresa let me
tell you something lovies
you will not get any middle east peace
you will not i promise you i stake all
of my money on the line oh
what was that you said well hold on he
oh he got admitted oh
oh oh uh oh very bad news for democrats
because they've been wrong now
explicitly for a very long time on
important security measures speaking of
security measures you got to get
lifelock
how's that for a segway life lock you've
got to protect yourself when you are on
the internet
i know you don't think about it i didn't
used to think about it very much
you open up your computer you open up
your phone you say oh it doesn't matter
who's trying to get my data
you are wide open you are vulnerable to
bad actors since the start of this
pandemic there have been
a 300 increase in cyber crime activity
hackers are becoming more sophisticated
in taking advantage
of teleconference accounts they are then
using those
to pawn information like your emails
like your passwords
it obviously you when the lockdown
happened and we all start going on the
internet for work for school
the hackers started going on the
internet more too they know where you
are and they realize that you're now
much more vulnerable
you could miss certain identity threats
by just monitoring your credit
good thing there is lifelock which
detects a wide range of identity threats
including your social security number
for sale on the dark web
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions obviously
but you can find out if your information
is on the dark web you can find it out
right now for free you can get a free
dark web scam
at lifelock.com knowles then you pick
the plan that's right for you
you save up to 25 off your first year
with promo code knowles that is a free
scan
totally free go do it right now
lifelock.com knowles
know wles and 25 off
with promo code noles a little
prevention is worth a pound of cure i
really trust these guys
head on over there right now so
they get this stuff totally wrong on the
democratic side of the aisle
what does the press do they ignore it i
mean specifically on this issue john
kerry
obama's secretary of state says it is
not possible to get this middle east
peace deal
trump does it in his first term that was
at the end
of the second obama term the kerry said
that trump gets it
within the first term do the press ask
questions about that
no because they don't want to cover it
they just want to downplay it and
thankfully
our wonderful press secretary be still
my beating heart kayleigh mcinenneny
comes out
and right as she's about to leave the
stage she rips him for it
what i will weigh into is the middle
east peel um
the middle east peace deal signed
yesterday that i did not receive a
single question about
that was the first time it's happened in
a quarter of a century if obama and
biden had achieved this
um they would look a lot different you
wouldn't have chuck todd saying he's
uncomfortable with the deal that
brings peace between the united arab
emirates and israel
and bahrain you wouldn't have seen cbs
calling it quote a business deal
and you wouldn't have nancy pelosi
calling it a distraction
uh maybe it's a distraction from her
visits to the hair salon but those were
significant agreements
first time in a quarter of a century
three piece deals in 29
days took 26 years for the prior
two-piece deal so
this uh the nobel peace prize nomination
for the president
two of them um very well deserved thank
you kaylee if he's a long order
president why does he keep breaking the
law
kaylee don't stop it stop it stop
hurting me kaylee i can't take it i love
how she does this
because it's not just that she goes out
and smacks the press she
lures them in she does this whole press
conference she's waiting for them
just okay i know she knew that they're
not going to ask any question about this
historic peace deal
this peace deal that that trump brokered
that was the first
normalization of relationships between
israel and an arab nation
in 26 years last time was 94 the time
before that was
78. you'd think it'd be big news right
they won't ask so she weighs and then
the very last point she goes okay and
before i leave
uh you all are a bunch of total hacks
you won't cover this because you're
nothing but democratic propagandists
okay good night see ya
and then what the best they can muster
is kaylee he's mean i don't like the
orange man
so the left has to ignore
these big news stories ignore how wrong
their politicians have been
how shockingly correct trump has been
but then they've got to go a little
further than that they've got to censor
him so facebook right now
facebook which is just another aspect of
this liberal
establishment facebook censors
a it's not a trump campaign ad but it's
an ad affiliated with
the trump election it's a pro-trump ad
an anti-biden ad
about how joe biden is going to raise
your taxes joe biden has been promising
explicitly throughout this campaign that
he will
raise your taxes he's bragged about this
we have him on videotape talking about
this
so this anti-biden ad goes out just puts
joe biden's
own words on the air and facebook
censors it because they say that it's
misleading take a listen
sometimes politicians accidentally tell
the truth
guess what if you elect me i can have
you your taxes are going to be raised
not
cut and it's true the new york times
says biden's tax increases are more than
double hillary clinton's plan even the
tax policy center admits
taxes would increase on all income
groups if you elect me i could have you
your taxes are going to be raised not
cut
big tax increases crushing our recovery
it could go higher
america first action is responsible for
the content of this advertising
so that is absolutely not permitted
on facebook because then we'd have to
listen to what joe biden's actually
saying and that would be
even less popular than the the current
propaganda around joe biden so
that's got to be censored now do you
remember do you remember
uh just this was just a couple of weeks
ago joe biden ran
an ad that said that donald trump
called neo-nazis very fine people at
charlottesville now we know that isn't
true we've played the clip many times
we've read the transcript many times he
didn't do it he explicitly said
i'm not talking about neo-nazis and
white supremacists who should be
condemned totally
joe biden launched his campaign on this
lie it was the very first thing in the
very first
ad that joe biden ran on and he's been
running on it
throughout the campaign another lie that
he's been running on
is that donald trump hates the soldiers
and he
has been deriding dead soldiers
fallen heroes overseas this is based on
nothing it's based on an atlantic report
from four anonymous sources that was
then quote unquote confirmed by
an anonymous source but you can't
confirm a report with an anonymous
source
countering that we have 21 people on the
record saying it didn't happen
that ad perfectly fine on social media
because that ad
hits donald trump based on lies based on
nothing that one's okay but a video
simply playing joe biden's
own words gets censored
we're not even in november yet we're not
even in october yet this is only going
to get
much much worse the democrats only
chance at this point with all the
momentum going for trump
even after they killed the economy with
this stupid lockdown
even with all of that trump still has
the momentum in
this favor so what are they going to do
they're going to try to steal the
election we're already seeing a lot of
evidence in fraud
yet again in new jersey we will get to
that in one second first got to thank
our friends
over at raycon i highly recommend
wireless earbuds
from raycon raycon's newest model the
everyday e25 earbuds
are their best ones yet with six hours
of playtime
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass a
more compact design a noise isolating
fit
raycon earbuds are stylish and discreet
no dangling wires no stems like some
others you know i was
given a pair of another kind of wireless
earbud
and you know i tried it around tried
around for a little bit of time and
it is not as good it it i won't get into
exactly
why i don't look i don't want to make
this some kind of uh you know comparison
contest here but all i'm telling you is
you can't beat raycon they have a 45-day
free return policy so you can make sure
that they are the pair of wireless
earbuds for you okay
they totally stand behind the product i
do too for a limited time
get 15 off your order at buy raycon dot
com slash knowles
buy raycon dot com slash knowles for a
special 15
discount on raycon wireless earbuds then
make sure to check it out
while this deal is running by raycon.com
knowle scannerwles county officials
in new jersey have tallied up more than
1600 uncounted ballots
from the state's july primary after
finding them
in some mislabeled bin last thursday
that's so weird ah gosh what are the
odds that you'd lose
600 ballots for a state primary it's
just in a bin it's in the wrong bin
it was in a secure area though in the
county election office according to the
new jersey herald and listen they're not
going to change the results
of the july 7th primary race
the board of elections is confident that
all ballots received
have been processed and the security of
all ballots has remained in place now we
know that in new jersey just this year
we found out there was a huge voter
fraud scheme another voter fraud scheme
to steal an election
we know now that in my own town or my
town
for right now los angeles when you get a
mail-in ballot
your party identification is on the
outside of the envelope
that a little weirdo what happened to
our secret ballot why is that party
identification on the outside of the
envelope do you think some of those
ballots might end up
mislabeled in a bin somewhere yeah
probably
sometimes the left says that there's no
evidence of widespread
mail-in voter fraud the reason that that
that's sort of true it's sort of not
true the reason it's even plausibly true
is
we don't have widespread mail-in ballots
yet we've never had them before
until this year when the left pushed
them we can point to
lots and lots of examples of voter fraud
specifically with mail in
we have an election day for a reason we
have ballot security for a reason
we try to have voter id for a reason the
democrats oppose that because they want
people who
should not be allowed to vote to vote so
that they can steal elections
because they can't win elections because
they have very bad and unpopular ideas
so they are out now trying they're
trying to steal it through censorship
they're trying to steal it
through journalistic neglect and now
they're trying to steal it
at the ballot box as well which brings
me to
a video that i really enjoyed seeing
from a target and
this is a target a shopping center
not like a target like pew pew this
scene that came from target
gave me a lot of hope i know some
conservatives are reacting to it
in a negative way but i think they're
missing the point here there was a flash
mob
that showed up to a target they walked
in they put on a little bit of music
then they took all their masks off and
started shopping that's a big stunt to
say hey everybody take these
these muzzles off of your face and
i'm not saying that we should always
flout rules and
regulations but sometimes we most
certainly should take a listen
all right hit it
here they are we got some cameras out
got some phones out got a maga hat right
there
we're tired all with their masks and
then they take them off
[Music]
all right now they're doing this
outrageous act of shopping
if they were democrats they would be
looting but they're not looting
they're republicans so they're shopping
and this is considered dangerous
terrible violent against the public
health
all of the looting and rioting that
we've seen for the last six months by
democrats
that was peaceful mostly peaceful
firey but peaceful but this
is these republicans of all shapes and
sizes
all shades everybody they're considered
a threat
because they're happily taking muzzles
off of their face there are some
conservatives who say we
must respect the rule of law we must
respect all of these rules
first of all i don't think that a lot of
these mask mandates necessarily qualify
as the rule of law
i don't think a lot of these lockdowns
necessarily qualify as the rule of law
or uncon
or constitutional even
what we're looking at right now is a
situation where the left is not playing
by the rules that they want us to play
by
and when you want rule of law when you
want order in a country
you all need to play by the rules if
half of the country with most of the
political power
is not playing by those rules then you
certainly
should not play by those rules and when
we're getting into these issues of
muzzling yourself wherever you go
or of not being able to go to church for
goodness sakes
now you're in an area where a little bit
of orderly clever
humorous resistance is is not only
permissible but it's absolutely
called for something has gone really
really wrong with the left establishment
the democrats the media attack all of
this
in this country when prominent hollywood
leftists even
are admitting that something's gone
wrong judd apatow no
conservative no rock-ribbed republican
no trumper
has come out and he said that hollywood
has sold its soul
to china we'll get to that in one second
first i got to thank our friends
over at eero you know
especially when you're on the internet
all the time these days and maybe when
you're working from home or doing school
from home
you've got that great strong internet
everywhere in your house
except you know one of those places
sometimes you got these dead spots
you've got that one no i hate when i
when my internet goes out it happens a
lot
or it did until eero an amazon company
covers your whole home with fast
reliable wi-fi
inside and out and this is very
important because i know a sweet little
alisa
before before eero came on she was
complaining about this kind of thing
well we can't get the internet over here
we can't get the internet euro
makes every square foot of your house
usable by eliminating poor coverage and
dead spots
you'll have a consistently strong signal
wherever you need it euro is fast easy
to set up
just plug it into your modem and boom
you are good to go
you manage euro from a very simple app
you can pause for dinner get alerts if
any device attempts to join
your network it's phenomenal it gives
you just total control
over your wi-fi you need wi-fi right now
you need reliable wi-fi in your home now
more than ever be sure to go get it
we're
we're asking a lot of our of our wi-fi
euro can help yours
do more go to euro.com knowles enter
code knowles at checkout
get free next day's shipping with your
order eero.com
code knowles at checkout to get your
euro delivered with free next day
shipping euro.com
knowles code knowles
even judd apatow hollywood left winger
comes out and he says
something's gone really wrong here even
we hollywood left-wingers have to in
some way
censor ourselves because this liberal
establishment has sold
itself out to china for me i think what
i
what i perceive as more chilling is a
corporate
type of censorship that people don't
really notice which is
a lot of these giant corporate entities
have business with
you know countries around the world
saudi arabia or china
and they're just not going to criticize
them and they're not going to let their
shows criticize
them or they're not going to air
documentaries that go deep into truthful
areas because they just make so much
money
so while we're all going you know can we
say this joke or not say that joke
on a much bigger level they have just
completely
shut down critical content
about human rights abuses in china and i
think that's much scarier
he makes a great point that's obviously
happening i mean
specifically with regard to china you
can point to the movies you can point to
the scenes
this this new version of top gun
explicitly is taking the flags of
china's enemies off of it and just
trying to appease them
but it's happened in a lot of movies as
well so you got this problem
at the what you would call the corporate
level right it's not just the political
level it's
at the corporate level and it's not even
just that kind of cynicism it's at the
the ideological level too there's this
piece i mentioned it i think yesterday
on the show
from vox.com that
it says how beethoven's fifth symphony
put the classes the classism in
classical music
beethoven's most famous work changed the
way
we listen and how we're supposed to
listen
and it's a long
uh meandering read about how for people
in some groups women lgbtq
plus people people of color beethoven
symphony may be predominantly a reminder
of classical music's history
of exclusion and elitism they're now
trying to cancel beethoven's most
famous famous work you know it's the one
that goes done
they're trying to cancel that because
because why
because of classism no because they want
to cancel culture
we hear about cancer culture well what
is cancer culture about it's about
cancelling culture
and that is deeply unpopular i mean
that's a that is a
just one example in one symbol of what
the left is doing
they are trying to destroy every single
thing we cherish in this civilization
because their view is that the
civilization is rotten to the core
and we need to deconstruct it or
dismantle it or destroy it or
whatever term that they use of the day
and they want to replace it with
something else either their own
unfettered imagination or instrumentally
some aspect of some other culture that
we don't particularly cherish because
it's not
from our civilization and it uh it's a
seen as in opposition to the things we
hold dear at all of these levels
that is not a recipe for popularity and
so the only way that the left can win
people over to their side
is by taking them by stealing these
things by cooking the books it's what
they're trying to do
with this election we've got to get to
the mail bag first so i do want to
to mention that there is a news story
came out
a couple of days ago right when i was
about to go on the air to cover
president trump's town hall
which is that the daily wire is moving
to nashville can't you just see me
as a southerner howdy yeehaw
i love nashville when i moved from new
york to la
the only town that i spent an extra
night in was nashville it's a great town
so we're very excited i like la too but
but la has become
basically unlivable they're they're
killing companies here
they're putting outrageous onerous
restrictions on everything
often they won't even let you go to the
park or to the beach because of their
tyrannical flexes of power
the town has now been overrun by crime
and homelessness the mayor here
absolutely failed mayor eric garcetti
passed a zillion dollar bond it was over
a billion dollar bond
to fight homelessness and what happened
homelessness spiked in l.a county 12
in one year in the city 16 in one year
they've taken over huge
parks some of the nicest neighborhoods
many many city blocks
you just can't do it and now the state
government wants to come in
and steal everybody's money and stop us
all from doing business so
you got to leave at a certain point you
can't take it anymore
i do want to point out though that while
tennessee is a great red
state the governor very kindly welcomed
us uh some
members of congress in tennessee
welcomed us coming there
a lot of wonderful people in nashville
have welcomed us there is
one author from i guess the left wing
paper in nashville
stephen hale from the nashville scene he
uh
see i guess i'll censor this with my own
with my thumb
here uh a-hole moving to town ben
shapiro announced in the daily wire
coming to nashville
thanks we hate it and then you know he
calls us all sorts of names and
everything all i can say to that
as we get ready to make this move is see
you soon neighbor
can't wait i can't wait to see you there
in nashville we're going to have a great
time lots
and lots of changes don't forget as we
look at all this madness around us
people can despair they say oh my gosh
they're taking away all of our rights
they're taking away our ability to go to
church
they're taking away all these wonderful
things that we hold dear our education
our statues our traditions
sure true i don't mean to underplay that
at all
but chaos can breed opportunity if you
know how to play it
and that's how conservatives should be
looking to do these things because
you know the the world is all going to
go up in flames eventually but
but what can we do in the meantime to
try to make it work try to make it just
a little bit better
how can you make your sleep a little bit
better well you can get my pillow that's
how
that is how and that's how you do a
segway mike lindell you know mike
lindell he's one of the most famous
conservatives in america
he is the inventor of my pillow mike's
latest deal
is on his giza dream sheets which are
made from the world's
best cotton giza they are extremely soft
and breathable they're extremely durable
right now the giza dream sheet
are two for one so you'll get two
four one incredibly low price plus free
shipping with promo code daily wire this
is actually a funny story with two for
one because
i've been a huge fan of mike lindell for
a long time and then my pillow decides
they're going to come on the show
so i say okay that's great they say
we're going to send you a pillow i said
oh god i look forward to that you know
i'd heard my pillow's best pillow out
there
so i but we only got one pillow so they
gave us one pillow
i tried out this is the best pillow i've
ever used but by far
it's not even close uh trouble is now
sweet little lisa wants to use the my
pillow
so now i'm just gonna have to go online
and buy another my pillow and i'll
gladly do it i don't even care that i'm
not getting two for one i'll do one for
one it's that good
and all my pillow products come with a
60-day money-back
guarantee uh really tremendous stuff
they also have mattress toppers they got
all all sorts of great stuff
all my pillow products have that 60-day
money back guarantee go to mypillow.com
click on the radio listeners square to
check out
the two for one low price and the giza
dreams sheets
plus free shipping there are also deep
discounts on all the other my pillow
products too enter promo code daily wire
call 800 651 1148 for those
great radio specials all right
we are getting in to the mailbag uh
don't forget
by on september 28th we're going to
start broadcasting this show on the
michael and all show youtube channel
rather than the daily wire
channel so make sure you subscribe to
the michael knowles show youtube channel
and we will get into the mailbag stick
around we'll be right back
first question from carter michael over
the weekend i watched the godfather and
the godfather part 2 for the first time
i thought they were terrific and i
wanted to say that you were amazing as
michael corleone
you haven't aged a bit in your opinion
should i watch the godfather part three
i've heard it is not as good but wanted
your opinion thanks
you wanna know something i've seen the
godfather part one
i don't know 50 times i've seen the
godfather part two i don't know 50 times
i've never seen part three i haven't
wanted to do it you've got
two of the greatest movies ever made and
then part three
they they say it's not great so i
haven't seen it yet
and i don't intend to if you see it let
me know but i do i'm i'm so
deeply in love with the godfather films
that i don't want something to be
less than wonderful so i'm going to
reverse this you tell me if i should
watch it and then maybe i will
because just just when i think i'm out
they pull me back in
from anonymous dear michael in my early
20s and for the past couple of years
i've been occasionally but intensely
drawn to christianity
right i've been slowly reading the
gospels and find that many of the ways i
see the world are just
clicking into place however i'm fiercely
proud of my jewish identity
the state of israel and love celebrating
the major jewish holidays
not to mention there is not one non-jew
in my entire immediate or extended
family
so i feel incredibly conflicted about
potentially betraying them if i ever
decided to leave what do i do thank you
well
i can name some other prominent jews
in the history of christianity if you
like namely
jesus mary joseph peter
paul i guess all of the apostles
and so so many so many of the early
christians and later christians two
wonderful
recent saints jewish i understand this
is a real problem
because you feel as though if you if you
leave a religious group especially a
religious group that also happens to be
an ethnic group
that you're somehow betraying people but
you're not
the the ultimate responsibility you have
is to god
okay and so one would hope that your
family will
come around and understand and realize
that you you have to be responsible to
your god
but even if they don't too bad
you know you're uh christ says this he
says you know
if you do not hate your brother and
sister and
and uh father and mother you can't
follow me now he also says
love your neighbor is yourself and he
obviously is love it
himself uh but what does he mean by that
what he means is if you are prioritizing
something of this world even something
as as
wonderful and uh loyal and
deep and profound and important as
family over
god then you're doing it wrong
and this is obviously perfectly in line
with what what you would read in the old
testament as well you can't prioritize
anything over god so i would welcome you
to the body of christ
it's a wonderful thing i under i'm i'm
not trivializing it i understand that
it's
it is difficult i would recommend
reading andrew clavin
another jew who is a christian
ethnic jew former you know he was raised
jewish
and who is also a christian i would read
his
memoir the great good thing it's a good
way to navigate that there's
so many others as well but i welcome you
and wish you
uh all the best and look forward to
seeing you in heaven someday hopefully
knock on wood
from joshua michael why do progressives
think everything is a fundamental
human right health care voting and now
clean air and water
isn't it more accurate to say everything
they want
should be a right you mean like a civil
right or something you know
or like a just a law that you pass
the reason they say this that everything
is a human right coffee is a human right
now
is because they don't really mean
the same thing by right that we mean by
right because they don't really believe
in rights at all
right where would where would a right
come from well i would come from
i guess the natural law and the natural
law implies a natural law maker ties
back into the religious question we had
earlier and they don't believe in any of
that stuff they don't believe in this
eternal stuff
they don't believe that the nature's
even set by fixed laws the human nature
is they believe that human nature
is on a continuum they think that newton
was replaced by darwin
they and they and even even those
phrases are rife for abuse
because they they don't really
understand even what that means
but the gist of it is they think that
everything is always sort of sort of
changing and so
when we talk about human rights we're
just talking about the things that we
really want
we really want uh it would be nice to
have health care so it's a human right
modern medical technology is a human
right so that means that that
virtually everyone who ever lived before
us without modern medical technology was
deprived of their human right
and we will be considered to have been
deprived of our human right when medical
technology advances
so then what does that right even mean
it doesn't mean anything it's just an
expression
of their will and that's really what
you're seeing
with most liberal arguments is it's not
even an argument
from reason or from eternal law it's an
argument from the will and that's no
argument at all it's just saying
give me give me give me from thomas hey
michael with all the identity politics
going around these days and the left's
fascination with men being able to
identify as and be treated as women
when do you think it will become a
common leftist ideology for people to
identify
as and be treated by the left as another
race i ask because despite being a
straight white male i would certainly
love to convince leftists that i'm
actually a lesbian black woman and get
them to pay me reparations since of
course
it was democrats who kept slavery and
racial bigotry alive love to hear your
thoughts well
you're already seeing this a little bit
with the rachel dolezals and there was
that professor recently
because there are certain legal
advantages associated with race
now they say they they pretend that
there are legal advantages associated
with being white but there aren't right
the the only legal racism or racial
discrimination we have in the country
is affirmative action it gives you a
privilege an advantage
if you are black or hispanic for example
and it gives you a disadvantage
if you are white or asian and so
no surprise that there are white people
a number of them now
very prominently who have pretended to
be black so that they can get certain
legal and social advantages
this i don't think will be accepted at a
broad level however because
the the left does not care about any of
these issues
per se they don't care about one race
over another
because of that race or because as we
were just saying because of some eternal
principle they're doing it
instrumentally to gain power
and and you don't need to take my word
for it i mean that the theorists
the and the political philosophers who
plotted out this kind of regime
especially in the 20th century
said this explicitly he said what we
need to do i mean and the organizers who
did it too so lolinski was very
prominent in this
you got to divvy up the electorate in
this way create new identity groups give
them
some special privileges buy them off and
then
they will vote for you and you will get
more power i mean this was
explicitly the argument for creating
lots of new racial identity groups that
previously had not existed
and and people were even slow sometimes
to identify with those groups
until the the left decided to start
offering the money and privileges for it
so
i don't think that's going to be
mainstreamed because the the very point
of it is to keep
the people that they want to keep out of
it out and the people that they want to
bribe
bribed from gabriel hey michael i was
talking with a friend today about our
country and one of the things he said
was that he believed that our country
was mostly being run
by white supremacists what is your take
on this
and how would you refute it thank you
for all that you do and love your show i
think that's probably why
the why i couldn't even read that
question is because i've already refuted
it that was the premise of the last one
there are legal advantages uh based on
race in this country but it's not based
on white supremacy
from patrick dear fiery but mostly
peaceful knowles
many on the right believe that the 1960s
were the turning point in the decay of
our society
due to the sexual revolution increased
secularization
second wave feminism fading of american
exceptionalism
etc how can you convince someone on the
left
that this has led to a lot of the chaos
we're living through
when they think most of those things are
net benefits
to society and trump is the source of
all of the chaos i appreciate
your thoughts yeah i suppose you just
have to go
further back than the 60s i agree with
you that the 60s were a turning point
but what what some of those people i
think fail to do is connect
the premises of the 1960s and their rosy
rose-colored glass version of the 1960s
with the mayhem we're seeing now
you know the uh the sort of the idealism
of the 1960s
compared to the decay of the 1970s even
you saw
you know i guess to use a good example
from
the 1960s you take a bunch of drugs and
you get really high
and you feel euphoric for a period of
time and then
you have a hangover or you have
withdrawal or you have
addiction or you have misery
all of that is because of the drugs
but if you only remember the euphoria
then you're still going to be pro-drug
even though you see what happened
afterwards same thing with this free
love
free love is pretty good for a short
period of time at least it feels pretty
good
but then you have disease then you have
heartbreak then you have sexual assault
then you have unwanted pregnancy that
can lead to children being abused then
you have
all of these kinds of awful social
consequences
but if all you remember is the heat of
the moment then you say oh that was
pretty good
so you have to to show that connection
obviously trump couldn't have started
the decay the decay
in the chaos has been going on long
before donald trump but you what you
have to do is show the connection
between
cause and effect and you you have to
show people that there's no such thing
as a free lunch or free love or a free
high without any consequences from
andrew hey michael i never voted before
and i want to i'm just confused as to
why i should hillary claimed that she
won the popular vote by 3 million votes
which seems to me that that means the
popular vote doesn't do anything
because she lost that's true the popular
vote is has nothing to do with the
election
could you explain to me why we have a
popular vote or what i'm
missing as to why i should vote well
sure you should vote because
because if you're listening to this show
you probably have
fairly decent political point of view
and we want that view to be expressed at
the ballot box
but yeah the president has never been
selected by popular vote that is
a myth that the democrats try to drag
out every time they
lose the election but they win the
popular vote then then they try to
change the rules
but the rules even that come down to why
we would campaign in certain states
are based on trying to win the election
the way the constitution's set up
not based on the popular vote or
whatever
by the way if the election were about
winning the popular vote i bet donald
trump would have won the popular vote
because he would have gone to the places
with big populations instead of focusing
on the places
where the electoral vote matters so you
should vote for that
one because if the democrats do win the
popular vote
you want to be able to mitigate their
bragging about how they won the popular
vote
but you should vote because we have a
self-governing republic and that's the
way the system works right now and we
want the good guys to vote more than
the less good guys to vote all right
take one more question from dave hey
michael when the infamous nbc tape came
out trump was quoted as saying that when
you're a star women will let you do
anything
including grabbing them in their private
parts how has
no one made the connection that this is
exactly what joe biden is accused
of doing actually doing with tara reid
trump
didn't say he actually did that although
no one would be surprised if he did
but joe biden is actually accused of
this very act actually no
actually it's a little bit different
than that because what trump is saying
is when you're a star they let you do it
right and so when people say that he's
he was he's
bragging about sexual assault by
definition he's not right really what
he's doing is just
telling a locker room joke to billy bush
but
in his very language by definition he's
saying they let you do it so it's not an
assault
what joe biden is accused of actually
doing
she did not let him do and joe biden was
not a star by the way he was a
politician in dc
okay so it doesn't even qualify on the
premise of what trump is saying
but the key here is is the consent right
trump's the premise of trump's joke is
that there is consent
the premise of what joe biden is
actually being accused of doing is no
consent
i'm just going to do it but why are they
not focusing on this this blatant
hypocrisy
because they don't have to because they
don't have to because nobody's going to
hold them to account to do that
and because of projection projection
where the democrats accuse their
opponents of doing
the very things that they do democrats
accuse republicans of
being soft on russia democrats have just
spent 100 years being soft on russia in
this country
but all of a sudden they flip it they're
not going to be held to account that's
why
we're in a less uh deliberative time
that's why
we've got to be a little bit clever and
take all of this chaos and try to breed
some opportunity that's our show
i'm michael knowles that's the michael
knowles show see you on monday
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire
20 20. if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle well
tune in to the ben shapiro show we'll
get a whole lot of that and much more
see you there
you